how long have you guys known each other
you bobbing on yeah I came out here in
2000 yeah that's what that's got to be
at then and uh yeah that's not you
that's when I met you because you know
who I remember the day I remember that I
know exactly where it was when I made
well cuz I never met anybody like you
I'm Rice as he rises nobly this is
something I like what you said when you
say that right because who said that
about me the other day - somebody said
that that there's no one out there
Neal Brennan said that your brother
pulled me aside he goes I just want you
know like no one on earth yeah and I
don't you think it's not a compliment he
goes but you just respond and talk and
you have a point of view that I don't
understand or why one path but that's
you and that's what makes you you're AB
you soul of awesome fun energy but when
you met me though you had never met
Chiney an Asian person like me not one
as fun as you the ones I met were really
good at math they're really smart
I've seen those do you there were shy
guy right right shy which I you were
like you see my dear were picking on me
you see my dick I have seen your dick in
hard harsh I'm pretty sure it's hard
you've seen my dick in hard for me I
know now that I have you know that I've
seen yours yes we have apart for me
white yeah you know when do we go there
when do we go can I tell you the story
permission because I'm gonna cut it out
but I do want to harsh Chris I want to
say something for you have kids and I
want you to tell a story okay I do have
a kid and a mother and a mother and it's
okay I'm prepared it's time people know
why and but there is I built up this
moment this actual moment in my brain a
long time right yeah and I'm so happy
that it's finally it's like a yeah oh my
back for a long time yeah it is one of
the wait timeout does anyone else in
this room don't know
no idea you guys know night and also
second I know everything about him okay
secondly I've wanted to tell the story
10,000 times and I've been in like Opie
and Anthony or other places where I went
I'm about to tell it and then something
in my head goes John that's the good one
being in you man right that makes me
want to go over there and hug you yeah
but Dom okay squeeze on so um John John
at the time his best friend at the time
one of his best was Jeff Richard yes we
started comedy together in Raleigh North
Carolina right he came out here a year
to before me and then I came out and
stay on his couch for a while right got
to do it that's how I met you tell you
about me yeah and if you don't like tell
that real quick yeah oh I met you it was
at Dublin's and they were a Tuesday
night and Jeff had been talked at
telling me about you for a while and I
remember sitting out there there's a
little outdoor smoking area and you're
out there smoking and it was me it was
Jeff and it was I think Oh Shaq was
around and maybe John got sick oh you
told me about John Watson yes and I just
you know I because my dad died a month
ago so I've been really like it's okay
don't say but I've been really like kind
of nostalgic and like really kind of
looking at my life in a somber kind of a
way and also try to prepare myself for
death but I but you find need to prepare
myself you feel more yes and so when
people bring up the past a little bit
and I have fond memories or I miss those
days or there's something I get a little
emotional but some get emotional about
the idea the story you're about to tell
well just the introduction was sweet I
mean it was like that does it stay sweet
okay I never liked where I grew up
football players joked around with each
other they were the ones kind of bully
you know would take your head yeah
ever met anyone like you but what size
what town from the south did you grow up
I grew up in Hickory North Carolina
right here great Hickory hard to see you
do I can't do you're honest so when you
grew up there arm
used you probably grew up with a lot of
white mostly mostly white mostly white
people right then it goes I guess white
black I guess you should know no Mexican
right Asian right and then other other
white stuff why exactly what it is Yeah
right so but but it's like when Theo von
when he grew up he found out that there
were an Asian kid and moved in the town
so him and his friends saved money for
bus ride because it was they went over
there to visit and it was a it was a
rumor yeah it wasn't even true so they
made it out there
and it was like a Mexican with Down
syndrome might go ahead so Iowa had
never met anyone like you who was as
forward and both you know just I think
the first thing you said to me Jeff goes
hey this is my friend Bobby Lee hey Bob
this my friend John from North Carolina
and you said you made some hick joke
which is funny and then you back set you
back hit my sack yeah you back tapped
yeah yeah
you back tap my sack for long we were
good friends and your huh man if I if I
look back on my behavior back then cuz
I've had Dane cuz day I did it game back
then
okay you punch of you I just want to
apologize because I don't do that [ __ ]
no more it doesn't bother me I know but
it's still it's still it's good it's
good to know that aggressive word about
its forceful and yeah I just regret some
of that behavior but um what made me
like you instantly I love you too yeah
yeah so then what so there's no that's
how I met that's how I met you and then
it was cool and then I remember taking
you to the airport sometimes you did I
think
pick me up to one time
real friends yeah you waited at the gate
which she never did you would get out
yeah or 911 you could do yeah you could
do but not before 911 yeah yeah so I
yeah so we and we went out to eat many
times you take me to Jerry's deli I
think after a set of the Comedy Store
everyone's shit-faced and you'd be like
what do you want John I'm like I don't
know I'm not that hungry like get
everything you just buy tons of [ __ ] I
don't want to eat all of it I'd be like
this is great so we've had many good
times many good meals many good meals
yeah good laughs